[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
félicie aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dans un coin du bois de boulogne
que j'ai rencontré félicie et l'arrivée
de la bourgogne et moi j'arrivais en
taxi je trouvais vite une occasion
d'engager la conversation il faisait un
temps superbe
je me suis assis sur l'herbe mais ici
aussi je pensais les arbres bourgeonnent
et les gueules de loup boutonne
mais ici aussi près de nous siffler en
mer la la rose et faisait des perles
mais ici aussi un clocher sur les tout
proche il a vécu pour le club
bézy aussi afin que ces thérapies chatte
je l'emmène il est chez chartier comme
elle est fluide et d'élite est elle pris
dans les bouchons guider et pendant
qu'elle mangeait le sien j'y vis du pied
avec le mieux rien omar sauce tomate
il avait du poids de l'eau pacte glace
il sort de beaulieu aurait dit une
andouille pays
je vaux frileux cipla et lempaut mais
méchamment
boire
[Musique]
dans la rame en temps la tête elles
n'eurent murat dans du goudron
alors j'en ai ma conquête dans un hôtel
tout prévoir c'était l'hôtel d'abyssinie
et du calvados
réunis et la chambre ordinaire
elle était pleine de poussière
[Musique]
je l'avais même bien vite le lavabo avec
une fuite
[Applaudissements]
sous l'armoire y avait une cale quartier
des titres en cas d' ici
et détail reprend le moule chatouillait
légumes en félicite
avi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]